this is remarkable Sean one of the Comey
memos is James Comey putting together to
the details of a late January 2017
dinner in the green room at the White
House with the President of the United
States we've heard about this before it
was leaked out to the New York Times
many months ago and it's since been
confirmed that the dinner took place but
yes what's new tonight is that James
Comey himself says that he told the
president in terms of whether he may
stay on as FBI director this is
obviously a short time before he was
fired it says I don't do sneaky things
according to the memo James Comey right
wrote I don't leak he goes on to say the
FBI gets a lot of the blame but in fact
I think they leak very little people
inside the FBI how ironic Shawn that
these memos are coming out on a day when
the president is tweeting about how he
believes James Comey has leaked
classified information by the way the
memos I have I should note are redacted
the ones that we're obtaining tonight
because we believe there's some
classified information in what Comey put
together and then leaked out through a
professor friend to the New York Times
and elsewhere remember Republican
Charles Grassley has said at least four
of these seven memos that were looking
at tonight
have classified information also these
memos coming out James Comey and one of
them again saying the FBI doesn't leak I
don't leak this is coming out Sean on
the same day that commis number two at
the FBI Andrew McCabe it has is facing a
criminal referral that has just been
sent today by the nonpartisan Inspector
General at the Justice Department to the
US Attorney here in Washington for
criminal charges for Andrew McCabe for
yes leaking information to the media
against the wishes of the FBI number one
and number two more importantly perhaps
lying to FBI investigators about that
McCabe today says he'll be vindicated he
doesn't think he'll face charges but
that is an ironic twist to this I want
to note another quick thing which is
that there is a point in here where
Comey recaps that January late January
2017 dinner and he says among other
things the president was talking about
quote the extraordinary luxury of the
White House which he favorably compared
to mar-a-lago of course his estate in
Palm Beach why do I mention that
remember there was this story
that came out saying that the president
had allegedly said that the White House
is a dump
he can't stand it it's not as good as
his properties the president at the time
said this is fake news I never said that
James Comey now and one of these memos
Shaun is saying the president at dinner
said the White House was quite luxurious
and better than mar-a-lago so I don't
know what version of events you can
believe finally I'll note I'm going
through all these pages are about 14 15
pages of Comey memos there's not a piece
of information from James Comey that
suggest there was any Russian collusion
that he talked to the president about
that and I'm talking I just got off the
phone about five 10 minutes ago with the
top congressional aide who just received
the unredacted some of the under
attacked adverse of this is saying that
there's nothing new on collusion and
nothing new on obstruction so this is
remarkable that early in the Comey book
tour as he faces questions about his
candor the Comey memos are narked and
now coming out and don't really seem to
have any blockbuster Shaun and I can
also confirm that when I first
interviewed the president right after he
took office he said to me the most
luxurious place he's ever been and so
that's a fascinating tidbit and also 18
USC 793 which we have been informing
this audience about you cannot leak
classified information great report
we're going to check in with you in a
little bit keep combing through that as
it comes in